hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that was played in the
fide women's Grand Prix between Maria
music and Alexandra costenuka and it's a
game that features a most remarkable
move that was not played for a while now
I've been saying that every every chess
game can be summarized via a single
square and some of you guys probably are
thinking that I'm joking when I say this
but every game if inspected with you
know sufficient
analysis will provide us the answer that
it is indeed so so let's check it out
and see why I'm constantly repeating
this and why you should always be aware
of this uh Maria with the white pieces
opens with E4 we have E5 Knight to F3
Knight to C6 and the bishop to C4 the
Italian game is on the board Bishop to
C5 The Joker piano and now castles this
is already a slight inaccuracy not
really but you of course know what I'm
referring to Knight to F6 with D3 and
here Alexandra castles and now C3 is the
main move here Maria goes for H3 uh D5
now striking in the center attacks the
bishop e captures and now Knight
captures on D5 we have Rook D1 going
after the E5 Pawn but now just Bishop to
E6 this is a very well known move uh
black is not
um uh gambiting a pawn here or
blundering upon if if you were to
capture the spawn you could resign on
the spot the problem is after captors
captures and captures uh there's the
very annoying Bishop captures an F2
check and now you have to move the king
and Black's position is just better
because if you capture them Queen F6
check gobbles up The Rook on E5 so after
Bishop to E6 we have C3 and now uh there
are a few games uh top tier games even
where Bishop to B6 was played uh for
example kayaking had it against arunyan
also alexenko headed against Anand um uh
a lot of out of very top tier games that
really disposition where Bishop to B6
was played but here we have pawned the
A5 and it is now as of 9 that we have a
completely new game and A5 is a great
move as it stops white from playing B4
so here Bishop to B5 now going after the
Knight so you can gobble up the pawn
Knight to A7 now attacks the bishop and
Bishop goes back Bishop a for we have B5
attacks the bishop Bishop back to C2 and
not Knight the C6 and it seems like one
black uh achieved some progress here
advancing the pawns all the way to A5
and B5 but white has the central D for
strike and this is uh very strong as it
frees up the D3 Square for the White
Queen we'll put pressure on H7 and also
on that V5 pawn and okay e captures on
D4 and now Queen to D3 going for
checkmate and probably safest is the uh
just to go back with the Knight if
Knight to F6 then lets the queen
captures on B5 you have to defend the
bishop Queen to D6 defends the bishop
and now if Bishop to F4 trying to kick
away the black queen from the defense of
the bishop you just trade capture scale
captures and now let's say rotate the d8
and everything is perfectly fine
uh however the game continued much uh
differently G6 was played uh which okay
you no longer have to worry about this
diagonal but you have weakened your king
side a little bit we have Queen
characters on B5 attacking the bishop
Queen to D6 defending and now Knight
beat the D2 threatening to win the game
on the spot with Knight T4 this will
attack the queen and the bishop then
you're just gonna lose a piece so Rook
ate the B8 chases away the White Queen
Queen to F1 and now Knight to E3 a
beautiful uh move by by Alexandra
um offering a knight but only only for
the moment you will uh recapture your
piece um
uh easily uh and there's no way uh to
actually decline this uh because the
bishop and C2 is hanging as well and you
don't have a time for a move like Queen
to D3 if you do this then Bishop to F5
and then you have all sorts of problems
so instead after Knight E3 just captures
F captures on E3 we have D captures on
E3 now you cannot save the Knight if you
try something like Knight to E4 then
just E2 check and that's it uh game over
uh so after this D captures an E3 we
have kinked the H1 and now E Capture
some D2 okay winning back material
Knight capture Sunday you can't capture
back with the bishop as you have to keep
an eye on your B2 Pawn uh so uh Knight
captures on D2 and now uh the position
is very very uh critical uh black has
this beautiful Bishop pair here uh very
very unpleasant situation for white but
if white can uh play this properly and
the defend well uh White should have the
uh the upper hand uh however in the game
F5 was displayed and this now allows uh
Maria to win the game on the spot like
literally on the spot so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
idea while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on always spotting
the essence of every chess game and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Pawn to B4 this is the move
that if it was played in the game we
would probably see uh resignation here
there's no question about it uh and the
problem is how do you not play this move
uh one thing that comes to mind
immediately is just to Rook captures an
E6 and once you see this let's say Rook
captures an E6 Queen captures Bishop B3
now attacks the queen and the king is on
the same diagonal the problem is there's
Rook captures on B3 black just gives
back some material and nothing really
happening here so here uh the problem is
after this queen captures an E6 move you
don't play Bishop to B3 you play B4
right away uh so this is one way to do
it it's not the greatest way the best
way is to play B4 B4 even capturing on
E6 but even this would be fine because
now you're attacking the uh also
threatening Bishop to B3 so let's say
queen moves you're gonna capture on Z5
and even if Queen captures and C3 looks
like the bishop and The Rook are hanging
you can play Bishop B3 check and now if
Rook captures on B3 trying to pick up
the rook and A1 Knight captures Now The
Rook is defended and if A4 trying to
dislodge the Knight Bishop to D2 attacks
the queen and if Queen to C2 then Rook
C1 and all of your troubles just go away
if Queen T4 you can even play Rook C4
pick up the pawn uh easy game but the
absolute best way to do it is not to
capture the bishop is just to play B4
and now it resigns uh the problem is uh
there is now nothing black can do Rook
captures and E6 will just be a free
piece uh and if you play a capture some
B4 then uh still Rook captures on E6
Queen captures and Bishop to B3 will be
even uh even worse so there there's
really no move black can play after Pawn
to B4 there is no more black and play
here so it's uh very interesting that uh
Maria decided uh not to play this as uh
if you check this then you find that
Bishop to B3 can be uh countered with
real characters then you just play B4
you stop Rook captures on B3 and that's
pretty much it she played the move
that's also good for white but it's not
like instant resignation she played
Knight to the C4 probably this is the
the idea that uh she had like a couple
of moves back and then she got the
position that she wanted and she was
very happy about it as this is still
should be winning for white uh so you
just stop looking maybe that's the
reason but that's why I always say
always check B4 like even in dumbest
positions possible check B4 maybe it
works but okay Knight to C4 was played
attacks the queen and now Queen back to
D7 if you trade trading is impossible
because this comes with check and once
the king moves just Bishop to F4 and now
you're gonna lose this bishop as well
the queen has no squares to keep
defending the bishop so instead Queen to
D7 was played and now we have a bishop
to H6 attacks The Rook Rook after d8 and
now Bishop to B3 still White's position
is incredible Bishop to D5 now the
Bishops here are also quite spectacular
with Bishop to G5 and now uh it seems
like uh White is very very close to a
victory but the problem is black now has
a beautiful move
add that allows black straight into the
game and Alexandra Sports it Ponte F4
and this uh now threatens Queen captures
on H3 and that's a huge problem that's
going to be Checkmate the bishop also
covers the G1 Square so you don't have
time uh to go upon grabbing King the H2
was played and now Pawn to F3 uh so what
do you play here G captures an F3 we
have Queen to F5 now again offering The
Rook to gain the F4 Square for The Black
Queen Bishop capture 78 this is uh
probably best is F4 but she goes for
Bishop capture 78 Queen to F4 with check
now King to G2 and now Rook capture 78
and all of a sudden it really doesn't
look like white is attacking anymore so
Rook 8 to D1 and now Pawn to A4 uh again
uh the the absolute best move and what
follows is nothing short of spectacular
look at this bishop captures an A4
Bishop captures and C4 now attacks the
White Queen and the bishop is defended
but that matters not just Queen captures
in C4 a temporary Queen sacrifice sorry
uh first uh Rook captures and the check
was played but you could play it with
Queen captures and C4 first uh Knight
capture 78 and now Queen captures on C4
this comes with checks so you have to
take the White Queen Queen captures on
C4 and now Bishop to B3 winning back the
queen queen characters a captures and
now uh look at the resulting end game uh
rook and Five Pawns versus knight bishop
and three pawns so with perfect play
should be a draw uh let's see uh how
they continued King to F7 we have Pawn
to B4 finally it happens a few moves um
too late Bishop to D6 and pawn to H4 now
we have Knight to E6 Rook to D1 and now
Knights the F4 with check King F2 we
have King to E6 and now Rook to D4 uh
Bishop T5 attacks the rook and just Rook
back to D1 uh we have Bishop to F6 goes
after the pawn just King to G3 Knight
the E2 with check and now came to F2 and
now the problem is there's no way to uh
to win the H4 pawn and black has nothing
better than the repeat moves here Knight
to F4 with checking the g390 to check
into F2 and it was in this position and
move 44 that Maria and Alexandra agreed
to a draw as there is nothing more to be
done here but what a spectacular game
and what a possibility missed here after
they spawn to F5 move uh of course
Alexandra saw that The Rook captures an
E6 probably
will not be enough for a victory but she
did not consider Pawn to B4 nor did
Maria here but you in your own games
will always consider it and you will not
uh lose or you know fail to achieve
victories in positions where Pawn to B4
is possible and it's possible in every
game at least once
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it always be mindful of that B4
Square I would like to thank Carrie
Smith Martin Aldine Marcus grebel bocho
and Kenneth Fraser for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens
with uh in the Chess World probably
covering the grand grand final between
Magnus and Hikaru so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day